solamente fue la primera mujer sino que
pues estuvo liderando el partido
demócrata en la cámara de representante
durante cerca de dos décadas cuatro
presidentes pasaron durante su
administración en la cámara de
representantes y deja este liderazgo en
la cámara baja del Congreso porque los
republicanos por una estrecha mayoría ya
aseguraron la la presidencia en la
cámara de representantes es decir Kevin
mccarthy que ya fue nombrado
oficialmente por el partido podría ser
El reemplazo de ella en la cámara de
representantes Esta es la razón
principal Además porque nací pero sí
pues ya también está bastante tiene
bastante edad y incluso dentro del
partido demócrata ya estaban pidiendo
reemplazos reemplazos que precisamente
Nancy pelosi en su anuncio no quiso dar
no dijo quién iba a ser o a quién iba a
respaldar ella para reemplazar en el
liderazgo demócrata en la cámara de
representantes Cristóbal vinculado a
estos últimos que nos decías Pero bueno
te lo quiero preguntar en concreto para
profundizar no Quienes se perfilan como
nuevo líder de los demócratas en la
cámara
Exacto
exactamente a quién iba a apoyar o cuál
iba a ser El reemplazo de ella pues hay
un nombre un hombre que está sonando
mucho y que muchos creen Será su
reemplazo en el liderazgo demócrata en
la cámara baja a pesar de que tengan
minoría es decir no tengan los la
mayoría de 218 votos Esta persona es
hakim jeffreys es representante a la
cámara por el estado de Nueva York tiene
52 años y sería el primer afroamericano
en llegar al liderazgo demócrata en la
cámara de representantes está este
representante y aquí en jeffreys fue muy
importante a la hora de los juicios y la
investigación contra el ex presidente
Donald Trump estuvo y lideró el equipo
de investigación que pues acusó a él
excepto el presidente Donald Trump
[Música]
pasó Donald Trump en los últimos dos
años de desorganización Y jeffreys fue
fue trascendental en estos dos
acusaciones hay otros nombres también
está Steve Harley de Maryland claver de
Carolina del Sur que también pueden ser
los líderes de la cámara representantes
como eventuales candidatos